we continue our march through Euclidean
geometry I just want to pause there just
to remind you because I actually don't
think I've said that phrase over the
last week or two that we've been in this
topic you could in geometry you might
see it's named plane geometry as in like
flat surfaces that kind of thing but
this name I really like this name partly
because it sounds cool and also because
Euclid was one of those ancient Greek
guys like Pythagoras to whom we owe a
lot of the mathematics that we learn and
just contemplate that for a second
2,300 years ago some guys worked out
some things and they're still all truth
today that's why we can do this in
mathematics and the other field of
knowledge can do this we generally
overturn what previous people thought
was true we're like actually we know
better
you know atoms don't really look like
that thing which you picture when you
picture an atom that's not at all what
an atom looks like even though that's
what my science textbooks said we have
better models for understanding this
right and we replace our old models but
in mathematics once you prove something
to be true I've said this before it's
true forever so I just want you to make
sure you've got that in the background
of your mind we're having a look at
similarity today the best way to
understand similarity which is
traditionally are quite hard to remember
part of your coding geometry is to think
back to congruence there were four tests
for Congress do you remember what they
were
number one we had a side side side
after that side angle side angle angle
side this is kind of like a nice logical
order in which to do them and then
there's the hipster in the group which
is RH s just because the rest is remain
straight now we know what each of these
means and we also remember that Congress
proofs are totally okay with these
abbreviations for this reason when we
say side side side or side angle side
angle etc all these things what we mean
is the features in one triangle are
exactly equal to the features in
the other right we mean the size of
equal length I mean the angles are of
equal magnitude and so we're okay with
the abbreviation it means the same thing
every time that's what it is for
Congress but when it comes to similarity
we make you do words because they're not
always the same things angles are equal
but sides are not equal sides are in the
same ratio or in proportion is the way
that I tend to write it okay there are
tests of similarity that directly
correspond to the tests for Congress for
test for comrades for tests for
similarity so let's go through each of
them okay three pairs of sides equal and
you've got congruent triangles but for
similarity we want three pairs of sides
not equal but in ratio or you really
should say in the same ratio or in
proportion so here's the way that I say
it three pairs of sides in proportion so
before this you might have written
something like this a B on PQ equals 1
over 2 if these are two of the sides and
then you might say BC on cue R equals 1
over 2 or 2 or 4 or whatever it happens
to be and then lastly you might say well
my left AC on V equals 1/2 so you have
established that the sides in one
triangle correspond to the sides in the
other triangle and produce exactly the
same ratios all the way through okay
it's important that you recognize what
you're pairing up the sides in one
triangle that correspond to the sides of
another okay so you can see I'll put
this in another color for you you can
see all of these guys they belong to one
triangle and then of course all the
other ones belong to the other triangle
so in these ratios you do not compare
for example a b and b c
because they're in the same triangle
even though if this is all correct
you actually could say that a B on BC
will be P Q on q ah that will actually
be mathematically true right but it
doesn't correspond to your reason you're
not talking about any corresponding
sides between the triangles
you're comparing sides within the same
triangle so your your equation and your
reason don't match on okay three pairs
of sides in proportion that's the
easiest one to remember the next one
tends to be a bit more of a hassle but
it's also not that hard think about the
picture you've got two sides and then
you've got an included angle let me say
that again to science included angle but
the two sides are not equal because
we're talking about similarity the two
sides are again in proportion so here's
probably the most succeed way that you
can say it sides about equal angles I'm
not quite finished with this but I just
want to point out this word we've
encountered this many times throughout
the last 11 years of learning
mathematics sometimes we take words that
are fairly standard words and we apply a
specific mathematical meaning to them
right so when we say rotation about a
point right we don't mean like roughly
in the area we mean no that specific
point is a center of rotation and when I
say about here I mean specifically that
this is an included angle and these
sides are the arms of that angle okay
sides about equal angles are what that's
what I'm looking for okay so it's not
just side to that equal in sides we're
angles angles what tell me what's going
on okay so they are in proportion
yeah it doesn't make sense really to say
angles are in proportion for similarity
because actually what you need is for
the angles to be the same so that's why
you see I've encapsulated everything
into that by saying sides about equal
angles and I'm done AAS we already
remember that once you've got two angles
in a triangle you have the third angle
right so if you have all three angles
what do we call that starts with an E we
call it equiangular equiangular if you
have all three angles BAM you've got
similarity and to turn that similarity
in two congruent you just lock in the
length of one side right so if you've
got two triangles and they are both
30-60-90 triangles then they're going to
be similar but if you suddenly make
their hypotenuse is the same length or
one of the short sides the same length
okay then everything else also falls
into place and that's how this
similarity turns into this conrad's okay
okay the last one there's no there's no
nice way to shorten this I like to think
that even though we have a reputation
for the arson the overage take forever
to write these are not so bad I don't
like the RHS one so here we go what what
important information do we need to
encapsulate number one we have to talk
about the fact that it's a right angle
triangle number two we have to include
the fact that it's a two other sides
that by the way its RHS it's not our SS
a right angle and two shorter sides does
anyone know why I'm highlighting the
fact that this hypotenuse which makes me
ask the next question
why does it have to be the hypotenuse
what why not like is this isn't this a
proof wouldn't this make triangles
congra okay so and this is what we
pointed out back when we were looking at
congruence two days ago if you had the
hypotenuse you can get the third side
but isn't that still true if you don't
have the hypotenuse and you have two
other sides like here's the situation
I'm looking at and once I draw it
hopefully will become clear if I've got
this triangle right angled
and this other triangle that's right
angle and I have the two shorter sides
and I know that they are equal thinking
about congruence for a second okay so
here and to you why is this not its own
reason look at the diagrams very this is
si yes you don't need any fancy extra
reason for this so in some ways the
reason why RHS makes it onto the list is
because it's a special case where in
fact if you have a look at now what I
just really means let's get rid of this
guy if this was just a triangle we
didn't know Pythagoras's theorem which
is what we looked at this morning okay
then these triangles we wouldn't have
enough information for them to be
congruent right because look it's not
SAS where's the angle it's it's not
included right so that's why it doesn't
fit into this category but if it's
right-angled then we can say oh wait I
can do Pythagoras to this I can actually
get all three sides and really it's a
subset of the very first reason so how
do we write the similarity that
corresponds to this again excuse me the
angles are going to be equal they're
gonna be right angles and then we have
to somehow capture the fact that it's
these sides not just any random sides
okay so here's the way I'm gonna say it
I'm gonna write all that and then I'll
read that for you okay
okay
so you can see why I don't like it it's
by far the longest I will point out some
people's form for remembering this one
is about as long as this one you might
ask why not just say shorter sides
plural and hypothesis plural okay I did
that for this one I did that for this
one here's the reason why
when you say shorter sides the question
is which one like because because there
are two shorter sides right and if the
shorter sides are mismatched then
actually you're kind of in trouble that
is different it doesn't match up we have
to have things corresponding so that's
why you have to say this important
phrase here or this word rather you've
gotta be able to say the corresponding
shorter side and there's only one
hypotenuse so you don't need to qualify
that statement okay